[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i am dave ramsey your host we
invite your calls nationwide toll free
the number is free and some say the
advice is worth exactly what you pay for
it the phone number triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two
five
so i have had the uh pleasure of
spending the morning with a ramsey
uh foundations in personal fire ramsay
um i'm sorry certified financial coaches
and uh they have done all kinds of
things so been in here learning all week
i'll be here most of the week learning
we've got an enrichment series going uh
we've got about we have several thousand
coaches across america
and people with big old hearts and big
old brains both to help you
with your finances and i'm coaching them
through
and giving them some ideas of stuff i
used to do back in the day and lots of
things ramsay is doing today to do
one-on-one coaching and to help someone
change their lives
and it occurred to me that some of those
lessons that we're talking to those guys
about are probably good for some of uh
some of our audience from our listening
audience as well
here's the thing that we discovered
that is a huge difference maker for you
now i get tons of people that don't like
dave ramsey because there is a segment
of people in our culture
that
don't like to be told
that they can win
if i tell someone that is hell-bent on
being a victim
that they can win
they don't like it
it makes them mad
don't tell me i can win because then i
that takes away all my excuses
it takes away the fact that i might have
to deal with the person in my mirror
and i if i convince you that your
category whatever category you have
stuck yourself in
i'm skinny i'm fat i'm man i'm woman i'm
black i'm white i'm purple i'm pink i'm
latino
i don't know what i am
i'm from the north i'm from the south
i have this or that
i don't know what your thing is but i
can tell you after 30 years of doing
this i've met one just like you who made
it
and if you want to live in the soup of
your self-pity and in the soup of your
victimhood
you're going to not like dave ramsey
so personal finance is 80 behavior
it's only 20 head knowledge
and once you get that dialed in
then you're in a place to go okay yes
there's outside variables
yes sometimes there's mean people in the
world yes sometimes there's racists
sometimes they're sexists sometimes
there's a whatever ist that's there's
jerks and foolish and ignorant people
everywhere
they're all around us
and yet it's still your job to control
what you can control and they're not one
of the things you can control
you can control the person in your
mirror
and then you
become successful tada
is it easy well crap no if it was easy
we would not recommend successful people
so
last summer
uh i guess it was last summer we had at
our entre leadership event uh one of the
sharks from the shark tank and uh he and
some of his folks and some other friends
of mine all got together at my house for
a big dinner afterwards we ended up
sitting on my deck and talking until the
wee hours of the morning and became
that night lifelong friends i'll just
tell you i just love this guy and i
heard he was doing a new project an
audible project and i got him on the
phone because i want you guys to know
about it so uh america's shark you gotta
love him damon john is with us hey my
friend how are you
what's up brother i uh i love what you
were saying as i just tuned in and um
and yes it was a very it was an amazing
experience being with you and your
family and everybody so really good to
hear from you man well it's good to hear
from you i'm excited about this project
so you're gonna tell people
how you built a six billion dollar brand
called fubu
uh i mean we get to see on the shark but
that's small potatoes compared to fubu
and you did this man started i mean 40
bucks you are a rags to riches story and
you overcame some crap without a doubt
to do that i mean you got misunderstood
abused and betrayed and everything else
and still pulled it off and uh which
normally happens to all of us but
sometimes people think that line of
success doesn't include that much manure
but it did in your case it did in my
case for sure that's one of the reasons
we became fast friends but talk about
this new audible original uh about
founding fubu what are you talking about
in this
yeah yeah so the waterloo original is so
there's there is no book to this that
has now become an audible this is purely
an audible original greatly produced it
is talking about my found my days that i
founded booboo what i went through all
the things and all that all the things
that happened to me good bad or ugly a
lot of the behind the scenes stories
such as you know you start having money
come around there's bad people and good
people to come around i didn't think
though that for your listeners they can
learn from is the community that was
built you know the same way you know
we're seeing too many communities that
are fighting because they're apart we're
not getting enough of the good stories
of people who listen to your show they
couldn't care less about other people's
color gender and race and all that other
stuff it's about communities you build
and and and really how we ended up
growing and how i made a ton of
financial mistakes a ton meaning
closing fubu three times from 89 to 92
running out of the first hundred
thousand dollars that i had and almost
being homeless and then blowing around
20 million dollars when i first made
money and i think that's important for
people to learn too because you know
fiscal education and responsibility is
something that you learn every day you
keep growing there's no way to just
arrive at it and i think that a lot of
your listeners can absolutely take away
from those big mistakes that i made and
thank god i'm still here
after making those mistakes
what was the best
financial decisions the best three
decisions best three habits or
disciplines
around money that you develop that you
attribute to being able to stay on top
of it
i think uh living within my means
and understanding that i think
understanding credit
um
and i also think
probably in general understanding how
money works from a taxes perspective
uh
from interest
and understanding how to allocate it
accordingly and i think all three of
those really uh kind of kind of stay in
tune and align with each other um but
you're going to say three i think that's
going to be the fourth one also the
investment you know being able to not
only have to go out and work for my
money but letting my money work for me
and not you know not taking as many
chances as you know i took in the past
because i had money i made my my most
my most ignorant um
or my most uneducated decisions was when
i had the most money that's when i made
the biggest mistakes
well you get you kind of get fat and
sloppy we all do right
yeah it's kind of like yeah that little
bit don't matter that little bit doesn't
matter i got it i got it all of a sudden
you're like holy crap i don't got it
you know how many of the shark how many
of the shark deals are paying you money
right now are you still making a profit
on
um i would i would think that around 3
out of 10 i make a profit on um uh
probably two out of you know because our
two out of ten are kind of the
they're kind of trying to figure out who
they want to be when they grow up and
then another five out of 10 they just
didn't work out they uh
um you know i don't want to talk bad
about the entrepreneur maybe having
their time but you know they made bad
decisions or
uh you know they didn't educate
themselves enough it's a three-hour
audible project called founding fubu you
can listen to it at daymondjohn.com is
that right diamond
absolutely all right be sure and check
it out guys this guy's awesome thank you
damon
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author and author of
the new book that's in pre-sale from
paycheck to purpose the clear path to
doing work you love is my co-host he and
i were both speaking this morning at the
enrichment
event for the
ramsey financial coaches uh and uh
it was a lot of fun you did a great job
of course thank you sir a lot of fun you
you warmed them up it's always nice to
follow you you you know the crowd's
ready you know they're fired up or you
know the bar set low
whatever
yeah no not the case it was a great
crowd these are the men and women on the
front lines who have decided because of
the baby steps and and the life change
and transformation that they
uh brought into their life as a result
of that clear path now they're out there
coaching other men and women and giving
hope and and you know it's just always a
blessing to be able to to look eyeball
to eyeball with those men and women who
care deeply about coaching others so it
was really really sweet sweet crowd and
fun time well and they know they're why
they're clear
they're very missional and that's your
whole message of the ken coleman show
and is with your career to be missional
find something you love yeah and pour
yourself into it so if you want to talk
careers ken is with us today you want to
talk jobs ken's with us of course we'll
talk about your life and your money this
is the ramsay show so it's all about you
wiley is with us in reno nevada hi wiley
how are you
doing well dave uh hi ken how are you
guys great having a blast
how can we help hey
so my question um i'm currently debt
free i've been listening to you for the
last uh two years paid off all my debt
um
my mom turned me on to you and i got out
of college debt-free so i'm currently in
baby step four and i'm saving 15
of um
of my retirement uh and i have i have
currently worked for the school district
here so i have a retirement through the
district the pension um i have a 403 b
and a roth ira that i'm all contributing
to look at you well done
thank you um it's all due to you um and
everything that you've kind of used i
didn't give you any money
true
uh so i'm just trying to look forward to
my future i'm looking to buy a house
should i stop investing in these and
just stack money or should i continue to
invest in one or is there a certain one
that's better than the other
either one is fine people do
all three things once you get to baby
step three which means you have your
emergency fund in place and you're
debt-free which you did a while back way
to go
then is when you start saving for a
house sometimes people wait a little bit
particularly if they're young like you
they wait a little bit to start their
investing and use all that margin to
pile up a big old down payment and
there's nothing wrong with doing that i
don't want you to wait more than three
years but if you want to take a couple
years and pile up a down payment and
hold on baby step four we
always call that baby step 3b around
here uh other people look at it and go i
can still save pretty aggressively while
doing my investing so i'm going to just
dial some of my investing back but i'm
going to do this other one over here
that's really sweet i don't want to i
don't want to get completely out and uh
can we see people go up and down that
spectrum and they all do well yeah
because
what happens is when you get to that
baby step 3 and you move to 3b and
you're looking out you have all this
freedom you get to decide what really
really matters you've got the discipline
you've done the hard work so now it
really is
i like that either or what's most
important now and begin to move with the
same discipline the same purpose that
you have been now you'll get there we do
not say that about paying off your house
sir no
we say do the 15 that's right and
whatever you can find above that pay
your house off early but for saving for
the down payment on the first house
that's right a lot of people uh you know
in their 20s or 30s will take a
temporary pause on baby step four a gap
year oh i like that day between three
and four i like and they all build their
down payment right and that's baby step
3b i've never thought of it that way i
haven't either actually it's good that's
pretty good i like that all right open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five tyler is in abilene
texas hey tyler how are you
i'm doing great dave how are you better
than i deserve what's up
well uh
me and my wife are new to you we got
married in june congratulations
from the ground running we
we knew debt was a bad idea
uh she came into the marriage debt free
uh i did not by a long stretch um so he
as soon as we got married got back from
the honeymoon started attacking debt
and working together to pay it off um we
really haven't argued about money at all
until last night so
our tie breaker so uh oh oh boy okay
so what what is the argument about this
is great i'll get my whistle out my
little strike my little striped i need a
flag too i could throw a flag on him
yeah that's it yeah all right go tyler
what's the argument
all right so i'm a youth pastor uh and
we were talking about uh once we get out
of baby step two about investing
and my cpa has talked to me a little bit
about possibly filing an exemption for
social security taxes
my wife is concerned
about doing that in case you know the
what ifs could happen if i
injured and couldn't work or or whatever
or disability wouldn't be wouldn't be a
factor in my mind behind it being a real
numbers minded person
say well we can make a lot more in
investing that we're getting out of debt
quicker if we opted out of the social
security
i don't know what you would
advise in that uh either direction or
neither at all
darn darn darn
i don't get to blow my whistle
you're both right yeah
so let me walk you through what how we
handle this okay
yes i believe pastors
should opt out of social security
uh in order to do that you have to sign
a document that it says you're a
conscientious objector that only has a
religious basis
you do not believe
in the social security
system and it's only for your pastoral
income by the way if you have another
income that income subject social
security it's only for your pastoral
income now i could sign that with good
conscience because i believe the bible
teaches us to be good managers good
stewards of money and giving money to
the social security system is by
definition not being a good steward
and so that's not a joke that's just a
math i mean that's a morality fact as
far as i'm concerned and so you're not
being a good manager if you give the
government money and you didn't have to
so i can i could in good conscience be a
conscientious objector i don't have that
option because i'm not a pastor so
yes i would opt out and yes you're right
you would make more money by investing
that money putting it in a fruit jar you
would end up with more
than giving it to them it has a negative
rate of return the social security
system does on average plus when you die
they keep the money you put in and use
it for the other people okay versus if
you put it in a fruit jar when you die
if your relatives can find it you'd be
okay they would have it get the metal
detector out in the backyard like
they'll be at my place right because i
bury coffee cans everybody knows that
not but anyway so um
now your wife is also correct the social
security system does three things that
you would be unwise to
step away from the social security
system without covering for those three
things
one
is disability
uh and you would not be getting ssi or
social security disability if you became
disabled so you need to buy long-term
disability insurance before you opt out
oh you need to do that whether you opt
out or not because the social security
disability is not enough to live on
so everyone needs long-term disability
insurance anyway okay
the second thing is you will not be
receiving disability at our social
security at retirement
so uh you will need to save for
retirement oh wait a minute you need to
do that anyway because we've already
covered they suck the rate of return the
money you're going to get at retirement
is awful you'll be eating alpo
so you need to have a retirement account
but not doing a retirement account not
doing this social security and not
having a disability account and then you
retire broke or you get disabled and no
policy your wife is right that would be
really dumb
okay and the third one is and it's not
applicable yet but if you have children
and you die your children get paid
social security until they reach 18
on your behalf and you would need to buy
life insurance to make sure your family
is taken care of in the event of you
dying before you're rich oh wait you
need to do that anyway
because the social security coming to
your kids is not going to be enough and
so i could consciously conscientiously
object and step out but you got to cover
disability death and retirement but you
got to do that
anyway
i'm thinking about being a pastor dave
all of a sudden so i can opt out part
time of course dave i'm not leaving
oh
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is our
co-host today here on the ramsey show
i'm your host dave ramsey the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five
two two five if you feel like you're
constantly running but nothing you do
ever moves the needle you can't get off
the wheel your money your life
you know that's normal most people feel
that way
but right now in our world normal it's
frustrating it's exhausting
all the time
but you can live the life you want where
you're dead free where you actually have
breathing room in your time and your
money but it takes having a game plan
and that's why we want you to join us
for our game plan live
we're doing a free
live stream on september 28th me dave
ramsey christy wright and george
campbell and we're going to help you set
a foundation for your goals and your
money we're going to give you a game
plan
now i don't know what normal is anymore
who knows what normal is i want to go
back to normal i'm not sure i want to
get back to normal i want things like
the old days i don't want things like
the old days um the old days had
outhouses and cars that didn't have disc
brakes
and didn't have penicillin i don't want
the old days um
you know i i like it the way it is and
so life life is pretty good but normal
as of two years ago i'd settle for that
but i don't think you're going to see
that again i think we have a different
world now so let's learn to live
let's learn to live and not sit on the
sidelines and throw grenades so we're
going to give you a game plan september
28th to register for the game plan live
stream text game plan to 33 789 text
game plan all one word to
seven
eight nine
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five marissa is in
bend oregon hi marissa how can ken and i
help
hi thank you for taking my call
my husband and i we are
really frustrated living in oregon right
now and so
uh we are wanting to move somewhere that
um to a state that is more in line with
our values and what we want for the
future for our children
and we are in the middle of baby steps
three and four
so just trying to you know your
advertisement about a game plan so just
trying to figure out what would be the
best game plan to
plan a move like this something we had
not planned on doing um at all we both
were born and raised in oregon but it's
just it's just too much we just it's so
heartbreaking the place you were born
the place you love the place you were
raised doesn't feel like home anymore no
not at all yeah so what is that what are
the key things that are driving you out
of there
um
so a lot of it is just you know the
unrelenting mandates
um i work for state government my
husband works for a
indian tribe here
so it just is you know one thing after
another our kids are just being
bombarded by
you know liberal anti-christian
views when they're in school we actually
live in more of a rural area so we don't
have any other schooling options for
them
um
so those are just the two big things a
lot of the politics just you know the
constant um
socialist ideas that are being passed
down in oregon
so i mean all of it
well the reason i ask is not to stir up
trouble but i think it is good for
elected officials to hear
why their citizens are leaving
right um and it's happening in
california new york and mass
it's happening in oregon and washington
state
it's happening around some of the major
cities where the city has lost control
uh they lost control of their cities
and um and and people are they are not
you know people who are the producers in
our culture who are the peop the artists
who make the art the business people who
run the businesses the administrators
who administrate the good moms and dads
who do show up at the pta meetings uh
they've lost their tolerance for this
stuff and um we're seeing one of the
biggest migrations in the history of the
united states right now
is since the time that this country was
actually settled
it's it's pretty bizarre so that's why i
bring it up it's kind of a philosophical
thing but worth talking about yeah
marissa i'm curious if you could tell
dave and i uh what's driving the
destination the most is it the where or
is it the what what you guys will need
to do uh from a professional standpoint
just curious
well i i actually work in a prison here
in oregon so you know my career field
i'm not necessarily anticipating being
able to stay in
but my husband is a farmer
he actually farms for
like i said a native american tribe for
their tribal government so he's very
much i mean he has an ag degree from
texas so that's kind of why we're
looking at texas he's um you know
familiar with texas really liked going
to school there
so his degree is in ag economics so he
can run
any part of a farm from the business end
to the manual end so
we're just right now we're focusing on
getting him a job and where where would
that be what would that look like
especially in the midwest i mean even
just uh job opportunities for him in
oregon the farming community where
they're out of water like
you know so
his his opportunities
regardless of the politics are becoming
few and far between so
so that's another another thing that's
driving our desire to move is career
opportunities as well what do you what
do you do tactically just to function in
the prison system what kind of a job is
it administrative in nature
what do you do
right now i run a life skills program so
transitioning work so i can do that kind
of stuff in a variety of settings
and i also have
experience in administration so okay um
a little bit more marketable
you yeah working for a different type of
environment
your career field might be can correct
me if i'm wrong more defined by what you
do rather than where i think that's been
doing it i really wouldn't i mean i
think it's i've been running a life
skills program i've been in
administration oh by the way happened to
be yes in a prison system yeah i agree
so once you guys get where the the right
gig is for the hubs
this is a wonderful wonderful job market
right now and you're going to be very
very attractive to a lot of different
people so i just wanted to ask about
that so i think dave at this point it's
you know okay we got to figure out the
place we've got a wonderful relocation
guide that i do want to make sure kelly
gives them uh at the end of this call we
had a ramsey relocation guide it's free
it really helps you walk through a
checklist of everything from real estate
professional uh schools packing
everything you can imagine because part
of the thing that freaks people out
about a move is not having a plan you
know it's just like what do i think of
there's a million things and certainly
when you're uprooting from one state and
moving cross-country that's terrifying
but we do have a great tool we want to
give her that'll help i don't even know
that you didn't know that yeah i talk
about on the ken coleman shows we have a
lot of people changing jobs
and so yeah
i guess i ought to know these things
yeah it's a checklist so it helps you
come up with a plan marissa we have this
great relay no okay anyway the um
the thing that comes to mind for me is i
i always have to put stuff like this how
do you eat an elephant a bite at a time
you said how do you lay out a game plan
i always have to put stuff that's this
big a task in
order
uh almost like a flow chart until this
happens i can't go to the next thing
and the first thing for you guys is to
land careers right
you can't go on a wing and a prayer and
hope somebody hires you
so when you if you both had jobs making
more or
equal to what you're making now in a new
market now moving starts to be
mathematically fairly easy
and that's another thing that's been
overwhelming is um you know
just the cost of living and our salaries
here are
quite a bit more than when i look at
like texas oklahoma kind of midwest
but i also know that we're going to be
able to buy a house that's probably half
the price of our house here you know so
just trying to keep things those things
in perspective too but when you look at
your technology
you can land the career
with a track uh uh you know land the
position both of you
then in whatever city and you say okay
that's where we're going then you can
start unraveling the stuff on your end
and making the leap but making the leap
until you have the income waiting on you
at the new place
is um that's really dangerous and so
that would be my biggest and first thing
i would do if i were in your shoes is to
you know jump on king coleman's site use
all of his tools to land that job you
love and this may be a time to
transition into a different segment of
your career field that gives you more
meaning yeah as well but landon land
that first and then you can talk about
selling your house buying a house you
can talk about moving you can talk about
uh actually loading up the truck and
heading to beverly hills it is swimming
pools and movie stars texas tea
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today his new book is called from
paycheck to purpose
the clear path to doing work you love
you can get it at
ramseysolutions.com and if you pre-order
it because it will come out in early
november and you should pre-order it you
will get over a hundred dollars worth of
items with it including the e-book
including the
uh the audio book inc including what's
other stuff in there well you're gonna
get the the get hired course which is
our digital course it really gives you
the edge to beat the competition it's a
wonderful little course we've got the
live stream event coming up november uh
we've got so many more goodies that are
practical tools that are kind of in a
suite there so that's where it gets you
that incredible value so that is a
fantastic it's kind of like you get all
the tools that allow you to beat the
competition that's what we're trying to
put together here to give people the
edge it's competitive right now that's
the way it happens yeah this is the
ramsey show triple eight eight two five
five
five jim's in sacramento hi jim how are
you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
good i've got a little bit of a pickle
here we
we sold one of our rental properties out
here in california and we have
approximately 310 000 in a 1031 exchange
by the time we were able to evict our
tenants and get out the market has kind
of climbed a little bit higher
we have uh we have emergency fund we're
on baby step seven no bills
and uh but the problem is we're kind of
just short on cash
without liquidating our emergency fund
out to buy another rental property
obviously don't want to take a loan but
i also don't want to pay
60 plus thousand in taxes
what would you do
you have 310 000
yes sir i buy 310 000 rental property
you can't you can't find them out here
that's nice not true
you can't find one you like
correct
but they're there i have
i have my emergency fund as well as some
additional cash but it would
take my emergency debt fund down to just
a low amount
explain to me what that means how much
money are you talking about
uh we typically keep about 30 000 in our
emergency fund so you're telling me you
cannot find a property for 310 but you
can for
uh 340. running well i have additional
money as well i have additional uh 50 or
so 40 50 000 in cash but i don't want to
want to liquidate every dime i have down
you know i would have to go down i mean
you're telling me you can find a house
for 360 but not 310.
yeah it's pretty close yeah
yeah and the market's just crazy hot
well i know that
but
um
well
you can do what you want to do i'm i
think you um
i it's just illogical that you can find
360 but can't fight 310.
i mean if you told me you can't find
anything for under 600
uh
but so my 310 won't work
you know i
will argue about that that's that's at
least a logic argument logical argument
but three 360 versus 310 that could be a
matter of negotiation that could be a
matter of finding one that needs the
gutters replaced
correct yeah i understand we're looking
at right about 380 390 and i have the
cash for that you have a particular
property you've fallen in love with
no absolutely i don't fall in love with
real estate
you have a particular property you have
your eye on
we're down to about 14 days to identify
a property in that 1031. so we want to
you know we've had we've got two two or
three we're looking at right now and
they're right about 380 390.
it just puts my emergency fund you know
down to about 1000 bucks
uh we make about 220 230 depending on
bonuses so your emergency fund's down
for one month or two months yeah yeah
that's kind of my thought yeah yeah yeah
i think you rebuilt the emergency fund
like it's an emergency and you close on
something if you got 13 days
but moral of the story is don't wait
until you paint yourself into a 13-day
corner so you get desperate and have to
make a move that's pinchy because this
is pinchy it feels pinchy but this is
all because not wanting to pay capital
gains yeah you could buy less that's
yeah
um and you could buy you know
hypothetically
you know go to another market even go
100 miles away that's what i'm wondering
and buy and buy 200 000 property you're
gonna pick apple games on 110 not on 310
then so you only pay on what you don't
use up out of this i despise taxes you
know this i hate them but but but i mean
it doesn't need to be the top the tail
that wakes it up that's what i'm
wondering if okay it's putting some
false pressure here i don't it's not
false pressure it's making you
prioritize the wrong thing thank you for
saying that better yes but it's like
make good business decisions first great
tax decision second yes
not great tax decisions and bad business
decisions that's exactly that's what's
bothering you yeah yeah you're right i
feel like it's just the wrong thing is
is driving the trailer right so i think
you're going to close on a 380 000
property because i think you can't get
your head off of it
uh that's what i think you nailed that i
mean he's got something he goes this is
a good deal if i can get it you know and
he's gonna get it so you make two and a
quarter no don't borrow money um you're
gonna do it and you're gonna take a you
know you're gonna run three months or
four months without a properly funded
emergency fund while you rebuild it with
a 200 000 income and no payments in the
world
so um but
god help you if something breaks in that
new rental the first month
you got no money that never happens
though dave
wow you're the real guy i'm with you i
think it's worth talking about i hate
taxes i do too i will do
almost anything except a bad deal and
that's what i'm getting at
paying taxes here's the guys at baby
step seven he's crushed it he's done a
phenomenal job with his money and to try
to avoid capital gains tax when your
capital gains on 300 000
is 60. yeah okay but capital gains on a
hundred thousand is you know
15. so
um you know you buy something cheaper
too as a possibility but here
guys you you um
the the pri
in the decision-making frameworks that
we use all of us use
when you paint yourself into a corner
and you start making statements like
they don't have any of those
that's when i start challenging you
because they always have one of those i
don't even know what those is yet
but there's always another option
when you start telling me there's you
know it's like bless your heart when
you're doing youth ministry and they go
oh
she broke up with me and she's the only
woman on the planet yeah no she's not
yes but by tuesday you'll see another
one
that's the truth that's the truth it's
fatalism thing you know god only that's
the one that god picked out for me
there's only one you know
there's another one had a guy say that
to me once he said well what i really
mean is she's the only one that would
love mango now that is possible
you're a real minister aren't you yeah i
really have a heart for people you're a
real pastor's heart it was a buddy chris
is in new york hey chris what's up
hey what's going on fellas
um i'm
i'm in a really uh tough situation right
now
um
i just literally found out probably
about a year ago
i had
a judgment against me since 2012.
i i never knew about it i was never
detected to check my credit or anything
like that
recently i've been trying to build build
my credit
and
when i got the letter in the mail i said
wait a minute hold on wait they they're
taking me to court for garnishment so i
did not understand at all why they would
take me to court
come to find out they sent papers that i
was never served in 2012
and they got the judgment against me
because i never appeared to court but i
never before i run out of time chris
what's your question
oh well i'm sorry my question is
is
they my original debt was four thousand
dollars they want
right now twenty thousand dollars i call
and i try to settle with them
basically they said no we want the full
what was this debt resulting from
uh this was a credit card debt
okay absolute horse crap they will
settle for 1500 bucks
and if you can't beat them down to that
i know if you can't beat them down to
that on the phone you need to hire an
attorney don't pay them twenty thousand
dollars
it's probably not even collectible in
your state so if it's eight years nine
years ten years old
yeah that's what i'm so confused by i'm
like
why
like i just didn't understand it well
basically
here's what you've not done here's what
you've not done you've not been
proactive
to start with you knew you had credit
card debt did nothing about it since
2012. and then a year ago you got a
judgment notice and now you're calling
me a year later still working on it
so you need to get on this man and get
this solved time to put both feet on it
now
if you can't fix it you need to spend to
spend 2 000 bucks on an attorney to fix
it and get it solved but i don't think
they can even collect it but i think you
probably settle it for a thousand couple
thousand bucks probably gonna cost you a
thousand attorneys fees
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice ken coleman ramsey personality
and career coach extraordinaire is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
your money your career
and how it all works together we're
answering your questions at triple eight
eight two five
five
two two five
so ken
this is an interesting and distressing
part of our world today
we did at ramsey a couple of years ago
the largest
by far
airtight
research
the largest study
of millionaires in north america in the
united states of america ever done
all the details
where they come from what do they think
about did they inherit their money what
are their careers what's their marital
status what's their race creed color
whatever everything we could figure out
and trying to find a and trying to
figure out okay what does it take
to become a millionaire
in america today a millionaire is a
million dollar net worth for those of
you don't know it's not a billionaire
a billion is a thousand million
it's a lot more
if you have
three thousand dollars you're closer to
being a millionaire than a millionaire
is to being a billionaire
as an example so it's not it's not
private jets and seven cars
okay that's not a millionaire a million
dollar net worth is not that much
it but it is more than most people have
there's about uh 17 million millionaires
in america
and that's what you own minus what you
owe
equals your net worth your assets minus
your liabilities is your net worth
so if you have no debt and you have a
million dollars in your 401k you're a
millionaire okay that's simple that kind
of a thing all right so we post on
instagram
yesterday
and this is what is societally
distressing
that from this study
not a feeling that we have
we didn't ask your broke brother-in-law
his opinion
we ask real millionaires 10 freaking
thousand of them
who they are where they come from
and one of the many
conclusions we drew from this was the
top 10
career fields that we found
according to frequency
within the study so who what career
field did we find most often
second most often and so on the most
often we found was engineer
the second was an accountant or cpa the
third was teacher
the fourth was management
the fifth was attorney
so not even making the top five is
medical doctor
by the way there were six
number six
but they were not even in the top five
and we post that on there
and instagram and facebook
proves once again
that humanity is full of morons
i mean if you read comments after
articles or comments after posts like
this you understand why some peace
species eat they're young
people are dumber than a rock out there
oh yeah a lot of mouthpieces some of you
listening are dumber than a rock i mean
i never heard this is ridiculous so
here's the thing okay we've done
detailed scientific research that proved
that the sun is hot
and we post it yeah on instagram the sun
is hot some of you morons will disagree
with that yeah
just because you think you have a right
to
and you should really stop before you
post something because it makes you look
stupid
okay was that unclear well probably i i
felt like you could have had a little
bit more enthusiasm for what you were
saying i felt like it felt like it lost
a little fervor no i think you're
absolutely right this is data and you
know what's funny is like people they
want to argue like we're duping people
yeah like what we're just saying yeah
right okay ramsay teachers aren't really
making that kind of money not where i
live i'm a teacher teachers can't be
millionaires no way teachers can be
millionaires no teachers should be on
there where are the nurses where are the
nurses well you nurses get your butt in
gear and i guess you'll make the dead
gum list oh my gosh well what they're
missing what these brilliant mouth
breathers have forgotten in this post is
that it has nothing to do with the
salary has everything to do with the way
they live
now engineers certainly can make way
more money than a teacher but it is they
have lived on less than they make they
have saved they have invested they've
walked the clear path the baby steps
their baby steps millionaires and that's
what they're missing here they think oh
i know what a teacher salary is you guys
are just making this stuff up nice as if
you're into cleveland i'll tell you what
all five share in common all five
professions are systems people that's
right they all work systems yeah
teachers work a a teaching plan they
have a lesson plan yeah they work a
system and they they if they somebody
gives them a lesson plan they don't go
make up their own yep they they follow
the lesson plan and engineers they don't
make up their own thing the bridge would
fall that's correct they have to follow
the system they have to follow the
processes attorneys have to follow a
process called the law you know you
don't get to make it up you have to
actually adhere to a process all of
these people adhere to processes for a
living and they take that same part of
their personality and they apply it to
their money and voila they become a
millionaire so what is the data on
teacher income well right now the median
income in the united states is sixty
thousand dollars so now before some of
you folks start firing shots at me on
that i said median you know what a
median is anybody know if you've been in
a good teacher's class you would have
known it's your law of averages you just
run your averages so there's no average
is different than median yeah i know but
i'm just saying if you if you look at
the across the board of what the median
salary is for a teacher it's 60. now
that means in some districts in the
united states like for instance i got a
friend who's teaching high school in new
york
upstate new york he's making over six
figures so this is across the board you
look at the median and now we go okay
this is what we're looking at in the
united states but again it is about how
they live on less than they make it's
not this study wasn't pointing to how
much they make it was how much they keep
and by the way there is one other
correlation between all of these
millionaires they love their work yeah
high quality
80 percentile range eighty percent
if you invest from age 30 to age 65
in a decent growth stock mutual fund 15
of 60 000
you'll have 4.8 million dollars yeah
there it is now you can also fire off a
bunch of comments about that but that
was math that you don't really get to
negotiate with math yeah that's how math
works it just is or it isn't that's
right you don't get to make up your own
version that's not enough so if that's
so if one if you only are there's one
fifth as good as we teach right
i mean five million bucks 4.8 million
right okay you would still have one
million dollars right and and from age
30 to age 65. she's but dave that's all
too clear-cut and simple for the
keyboard warriors
there's got to be more complexity they
got to tear it apart it's got to be a
game
and that's unfortunate that's the sad
part the sad part is is that we have a
portion of our culture now who rather
than fix their life
and address the person in the mirror's
deficits instead wants a narrative that
declares them a victim there it is
that can't possibly be true dave because
if that's true i could do it
if you're if your study was acute what
do you know about my study you just you
just
if your mouth was shut you wouldn't be
making noise oh my god
but dave they're mouth breathers so the
mouth can't be shut
seriously people
you really should abstain from the
comments section reading them or
commenting on them oh my gosh
ugh
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
this is the ramsey show open phones at
triple eight eight two five five
two two five you know i gotta i gotta
circle back one more time i can't just
can't let that lay um
there's a reason
that you and i both get so visibly
frustrated
with people that have a victim narrative
and insist on spreading their victim
narrative
we know
from having worked with thousands and
even millions of people
that most anyone that follows a proven
process can go get a great job can get
out of debt and build wealth can have a
good marriage we know that people that
are that choose to control their
behavior in spite of the negative
influences from the outside in spite of
bad things having happened to them and
we all have challenges but in spite of
the challenges we know that people can
create for themselves carve out for
themselves a good life if they bother
when someone posts a negative narrative
that says oh teachers can't do it then
someone believes that or you're in an
echo chamber with a bunch of people that
says teachers can't do it then god help
us teachers believe they can't do it
and we know that that's not true and
you've then limited someone's belief in
someone's future and you've brought harm
to them and we love people and we love
people that so much we want them to win
and anything that keeps them from
winning including you debbie downers out
there
we're you're going to be at the tip of
our sharp tongue yeah yeah i agree with
that and let me just say this as much as
we will take shots at people that that
are constantly negative and cynical
i i do even you could do it if you quit
doing that i feel sadness over that
because because you've bought in some
form or fashion a false narrative you
have had some bad stuff happen to you
maybe somebody did something maybe you
made a mistake and you did something
dumb that doesn't disqualify you from
being a victor i've never read a
biography in my life and i've read a lot
of them uh where the the story the
person in the story that we're reading
about always did everything right had no
hardship had no self-inflicted wounds
had no disadvantages so i absolutely
agree with you we get fired up on this
because we're in the business of hope
we're in the business of giving people
hope that they can be who they're
supposed to be they can do what they
want to do um and yeah it really makes
me angry when people just go nah that's
all a pipe dream and uh yeah it
irritates us and we live in a world
today where people really are influenced
shockingly by
if you really believe that
then why do you feel like you got to
share that with everybody else i mean
you you have the right to believe and
say and i will always fight for liberty
to say and be negative and your that's
what you want to be great but don't
bring it around the rest of us yeah old
country's saying if you ain't got
something nice to say don't you say
nothing at all
i mean life is too short passive friend
of mine used to say if it's not helpful
hopeful or promotes healing you don't
need to say it that's good
yeah it's not helpful hopeful or
promotes healing yeah you don't need to
say it yeah
and um
i can i could take to that advice
occasionally too i just called a whole
bunch of people stupid so but i think
that might have been healing though i
think it was it was it was a little
therapeutic for both of us yeah me and
you were healed by it
yeah but i will say this i think it's
fair to say that someone is stupid or
unintelligent when they argue data
yeah but by the way those are the same
people that go science over here but
we're going to argue something we don't
like and he you've heard this before you
don't like it yeah that's right we hear
what we want to hear we see what we saw
chamber city man it's just people man
oh man ryan is with us in fresno hi ryan
welcome to the ramsay show
hi how's it going good man what's up
all right so question for you
um i
made a
non-dave decision about four years ago
and i need your help getting out of it
okay
that's an interesting way of saying it
non-dave meaning it was a bad decision
thanks for the compliment but
how can i help tell me what happened
yeah so my wife and i
went in on a property
with her
sister and
her husband
and it's 20 acres it has a primary house
and it had a mobile home on it
so my wife and i we took the primary
house
and
they took the mobile home it was all
agreed upon everything good
um
we decided to split the ownership
50-50 uh
50-50 but they get the trailer
that was uh what we agreed on you're a
good negotiator
uh yeah so i pay a little bit more uh
for homeowners insurance just because we
are in the primary house
we have to have two
separate homeowners insurance just
i don't know that's how they worked it
out
anyways
my brother-in-law
they
either want us to all sell this place
together
or they want
me to buy him out
and we can't come
to an agreement on how we want to do
that we uh
basically our relationship is
just showered
and uh
so we're we're kind of at a standstill
of how we
how we can go about it
that's sad
yeah i don't know if i i don't know how
much help i can be with the relationship
part um
there's a i have a couple of thoughts on
structure if you want those
you went into it 50 50. so why don't you
just have the property appraised and pay
him 50 percent
um
hello let's say
yeah can you hear me yeah can you hear
me oh yes okay why don't you have an
apprentice
you put in 50 each put in 50 right
and he got the short end of the stick
and lived in the trailer
all right yeah and now he wants to buy
out why can't you pay him 50 of the
value what's wrong with that
well the the value is somewhere around
400 000 yeah
and uh so that would mean
so how does that mean i'm paying him 200
000 or just
he owns 50 of it he bought 50 of it you
bought 50 of it
we don't we don't own the home outright
though
we're still paying on a mortgage
okay
together
yeah
okay then it's 400 000
minus the mortgages divided by two
okay uh so if it that you're saying the
total 20 acres and the two pro the house
and the trailer are worth 400 grand is
that what you're telling me
yeah okay
and how much is the mortgage
uh we owe about 320 on it okay you're
gonna have to get that refinance to get
his name off of it for him to be free
but you've only got eighty thousand
dollars worth of equity you need to
write him a check for 40.
not really i'll come to that in a minute
but you're half you buy out his half
what's
why is that complicated
i just i don't want to go into even
more
yet
i'm just i think i'm having trouble
figuring out how to i'm paying him 40
000
and then accruing
the remaining balance of the mortgage
yeah but you also own the property 100
percent okay
okay instead of owning a thousand dollar
property now you own a four hundred
thousand dollar property
that's good okay and so uh can you
handle the mortgage by yourself i think
that might be the problem
uh
yes yes i can what's your household
income
uh last year brought in about 72
okay
you can't afford this
this payment by yourself can you
it's your household income you and your
wife
yeah my wife's uh stay at home okay
we have a uh we
run a small family ranch where we live
yeah i'm sorry sir i don't think you can
afford a 400 000 mortgage or a 300
something thousand dollar mortgage
350 000 mortgage on a 72 000 income
i don't think that's going to work well
for you your payment when you take this
out on a 15-year fix should be no more
than a fourth of your income i think you
guys are selling this property
that's what i think
and you guys are you and your wife are
gonna live somewhere else and your
brother-in-law's gonna live somewhere
else
it's a sad deal though it's
heartbreaking
[Music]
[Music]
all right ken i want to revisit the last
caller because i had a thought all right
the break um a solution okay so let's
revisit he and
uh his wife's sister and his
brother-in-law the four of them bought a
property together 20 acres
uh they live in fresno california and it
has a trailer on it and a home on it
they moved into the home the
brother-in-law moved into the trailer uh
the brother something's gone sour and
the brother-in-law wants out he wants
out of the deal they both put in 50
that's the property is currently valued
at 400 000
and they owe 320. those were the facts
going into the break okay
um
he makes 75 000 a year he can't afford
the payment on the whole thing if he
buys his brother-in-law out
uh it was my point going to the break so
that sounds like they're going to be
forced to sell out of the whole thing i
did have another way because he's he
also said i think he's ranching on that
property
so he's
i was not only getting rid of his house
i was getting rid of his his job his
sole income yeah everything i mean his
whole life's upside down so um i hated
to just throw in one of the bus head
into a commercial break
so here is a thought for ryan
um
[Music]
you can subdivide 20 acres
and take the 10
that you want to keep and the 10 that
the brother-in-law keeps
the brother-in-law sells his 20 acres or
his 10 acres and the trailer
is on that
he takes that money
pays half of the mortgage off because
he's liable for half of the mortgage the
mortgage is 320 so that puts it at 180.
did i do that right no no well
320 and a half is not one that's 160.
thank you i'm the money guy keep it keep
this in mind i was a little nervous
heading into that to be honest with you
i did some quick math myself i was like
before i questioned
that i thought i thought i thought dave
yeah i had to take my shoes off under
the desk and use my toes
okay so 160 000 yeah all right so
brother-in-law pays off 160 000 right
whatever's left from the sale of the 10
acres after he pays off 160 000 he puts
in his pocket and walks away
i like that he's just been bought out
now then ryan has to go get a new
mortgage for 160 000
only owns 10 acres has no money out of
pocket
and um
he can put that on a 15 year and survive
making 75 000. that's right but you're
not going to have 20 acres ryan you're
going to have 10 acres
subdivided
10 acres each brother-in-law sells his
takes these money proceeds for the sale
pays off half of the mortgage
simultaneously ryan's gonna have to get
a new mortgage at the same closing table
for 160 000 to give clear title to the
new buyer on the 10 acres
the buyer on the 10 acres
and the brother is going to get whatever
if he sells that for 400 grand yeah he
whatever the brother can sell his
brother-in-law can sell his 10 acres for
he gets that money yeah minus 160. he
has to pay off his half of the mortgage
and then ryan can keep his property but
he's only going to keep the 10 acres
which is all he ever had to start with
right because it was a partnership on 20
acres yeah so um now if ryan needs 20
acres to run his ranch i don't think he
can afford it there's the problem yep
that's the only asterisk there on that
one yeah so um
and you're going to have to find a way
to subdivide this but in most counties
in the united states of america you can
subdivide 20 down into 10.
very few places keep you from doing that
and sell it off and then the
brother-in-law got what he got and
that's his half you don't have to argue
about what it's worth he let the market
tell him what it's worth yeah
but he has to bring 160 out for his half
of the mortgage all right now we got
there i feel better about that solution
jonathan is with us in fort worth texas
if i pick up the right phone line anyway
there he is jonathan's in fort worth hey
jonathan how are you
hey dave i'm doing great thanks for uh
taking my call today sure what's up
so question i have uh my wife and i
we've been dave ramsey for a year and a
half
and debt-free for a year
a little background story we're retired
military
and retired in texas but through that
process we had a house in another state
i kept it as a rental for about the past
10 years
and now we finally got it on the market
and we're going to close on it next
month
so the question is
the gross
amount that we earn from the sale of the
house
do we
pay that on our mortgage here in texas
we also have about 120 k in a
traditional ira
or do we pay to roll that to a
and then use the remaining balance to
pay off our
texas
mortgage wow
well nothing in the list is dumb
uh both things could be under the
heading of smart
according to what we teach on the baby
steps i would pay down the house in
texas because i don't convert to a roth
until baby steps seven
i don't i don't want to create taxes
until i get my house paid off
and so um what's the balance on your
home in texas
uh so the balance is at uh 480k
uh we're on a 2.25 percent hdr and we're
on a
for the simple math it's a 30-year
mortgage it was cheaper at a third year
but we're paying it off at a 15-year
rate plus a little extra so i think
we're about on pace to do a
but the balance of the balance is how
much again
480. and what do you how much are you
getting from the property that you're
selling
uh we're expecting the growth of about
200k oh excellent okay yeah i would
throw it at the house
okay
here's the deal
i don't want to create taxes and give
the government the tax money while i've
still got house debt because effectively
you would have been borrowing on your
home to pay the roth ira taxation
you follow me
okay that's why i did that
in other words if you've got
you know let's just pretend that you've
um
you owe 200 000 on your house
280 000 on your house okay
and you have the opportunity to convert
to your roth ira but it's going to
create 200 000 worth of taxes are you
going to go borrow 200 000 more on your
house in order to convert to a roth no
if you use this money to convert to a
roth it is exactly the same thing in a
balance sheet scenario where you lay it
out on the balance sheet you created the
same thing you just did it in reverse
and that's how i decided not to do that
that was the the thinking critical
thinking path i use
to say i wouldn't borrow on my house to
pay taxes on converting a traditional to
a roth and i won't pay
taxes converting a traditional to a roth
in lieu of paying down my house it's the
same thing but backwards that's all
that makes sense
i was following but the speed and the
pace by which you do it it i have to
really catch up i really do you you you
know 35 years of doing this is pretty
good folks so that's pretty good stuff
well it's not it's not rugged but it's
just i'm well i have to think about how
the stuff is going where and
if i once i get that then i remember why
i have the baby steps that's because
watermelon is a lot of times what we're
doing you and me is your your clear path
your steps of your you know your steps
of uh the seven stages
doing things you love right yeah uh
there's a reason that they're there
right and when something comes up and
you go i don't know yes this is an
exception
then you go no because that's right
here's the way i did that you're walking
through this here's the logic oh sure
yeah
if you do that then you can understand
oh well that's why the baby steps still
work after all these years yep that's
why your clear path to doing work you
love will still work 20 years from now
well one of the things that when you
walk through that what it does is by by
using that methodology and the way you
you kind of logically work through that
it also takes out the emotion which i
think is so important you know because
our emotions get in the way so many
times just could be a little emotion i
mean it doesn't have to be some big
fretful fearful thing it could be i got
a little bit of doubt is this the right
thing i'm a little bit nervous about
this you know there's a there's a you
know cornucopia of emotions that can get
us into a place where we go
uh and it's like no let's walk through
this from a process standpoint that's
the power process
yeah and um
so much of what we are trying to
influence you guys to do is a proven yes
process and his question is really
really good oh yeah because a high-level
question very absolutely and and uh it's
also really good because neither answer
is in the stupid column that's right
it's not like he's got some bad options
do i lease a car or do i finance a car
yeah okay both in the stupid column
right so you know do i get a mastercard
or a visa that's right both in the
stupid column discover or american
distress yeah yes no both in the stupid
column yeah whole life or universal both
in the stupid column
payday lender or timeshare both in the
stupid column you know i mean both of
his were in the smart column that's
right
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today if you've been stressed
out about your retirement savings
because of everything going on in the
world should you really be concerned or
are you just in freakout mode you know
sometimes we get a little drama queen
inside of us right me as well
and that's why you need somebody in your
corner to help you with this stuff you
need someone to walk with you when
you're freaking out to teach you
to talk with you talk you off the ledge
and go don't jump off all roller coaster
in the middle of the ride
that's what you need to be reminded of
when it comes to investments what we
recommend is a smart vester pro they're
investing professionals that we've
carefully vetted
smart vista pros have the heart
of a teacher and they agree with us on
what we teach
text invest to 33 789 and you can find a
list of the smart vester pros in your
area one of them will sit down with you
help you with a retirement plan help you
with an ira rollover a 401k rollover
help you get your kids college set up
and then when the market goes crazy you
can even talk to them about it and
they'll tell you what's really going on
text invest to 33
789
steven is in phoenix hi stephen welcome
to the ramsey show
hi dave how you doing today better than
i deserve what's
up so
i've
made it to becoming debt-free except for
my mortgage
in arizona but
we're thinking about moving to florida
and i want to know if i should sell my
house in arizona and pay off on cash in
florida
uh if you're moving to florida yes
okay what's the sole purpose of that
question are you moving to florida just
for cheaper housing or are you moving
for for purpose for professional for
family what's going on
so i run a crypto mining business out of
my house here but i'm in an hoa
and we're looking for states that are
i guess more leaning towards the red
side more freedom um oriented but
i just have to convince my wife
um to sell our house here because we
currently have a mortgage
to just pay for one cash
out right in florida
without an hoa
so i can grow the business as well
have you done your homework on a
specific spot in florida that you got in
mind here is this is this all
theoretical
no so i've done research i'm looking
north of orlando kind of near the deland
area for about
around an acre or so this is what we're
looking for to set up like a mining shed
but it's just kind of convincing my wife
to
get on board with the whole idea because
it's kind of like a big it feels like a
big risk
why is it a big risk
it's just a big change i think and she's
just worried about it
maybe the mining business not working
out in the future because it flows with
the market
so it's not always profitable
right
but that's true in arizona and in
florida
yeah exactly so having no mortgage in
florida
while you're in an unbelievably high
risk business
um
would be less stressful than having a
mortgage in arizona while you're in an
unbelievably high risk business
how old are you
29
yeah
i think your wife's telling you she
doesn't like what you do for a living
for risk-wise
i think that's what's happening i could
be wrong could be some family involved
you know didn't want to leave family i
mean this is
this is a marriage issue here this is
some communication sit down and get on
the same page are we together the
problem is is you're trying to reduce
um
your entire life
which is your relationships your church
your where you shop for groceries
um
where
you uh
how how close you are to relatives
um all of that down to a decision on
whether you have a shed
or a mortgage
and um it's not it's not that simple
there's more variables involved and even
uh one of the variables is it that
you're in an unbelievably high risk
business
and um
uh
your your wife um
uh uh is
i think she may be saying that to you uh
maybe she doesn't even know she's saying
that to you but that's scaring her
um and because you know
but but it's not as simple as
housing is cheaper north of atlanta or
north of orlando an hour than it is in
phoenix which it is but there's parts of
orlando that are not cheaper than
phoenix so you know if you go north of
phoenix well not north of phoenix but if
you go outside of phoenix an hour
probably not north towards sedona but if
you go a different direction you might
find land that's very very cheap there
too without an hoa and if you sold your
house in phoenix proper like if you're
sitting in scottsdale which is a very
expensive market you could move out of
there and probably pay cash for
something an hour outside of phoenix so
i i don't care where you live yeah and i
just want to point out that what it
feels like dave is that okay
this is really risky it's making my wife
nervous but i can buy some more time
to keep going with this risky business
if i remove my mortgage and i just need
a little more time and and and i i feel
like there's something there that's
the governor of arizona is a very very
strong liberty champion so arizona is
not
the the politics in arizona florida blue
state no no they're not different so i
just want to point that out i'm trying
to take away the excuses yeah josh is in
nashville hey josh welcome to the ramsey
show okay
hey there anything
sure what's up
hello hello what's up
hey hey i was just i was going to ask a
quick question about some student loan
guidance
um i'm a physician assistant i just got
married
about a year ago i've been working for a
year congrats
yeah thank you
me and my wife have a we have uh a lot
of money in our checking account because
we don't spend anything
uh we don't have a car payment we're
renting a townhouse and we just don't
know what to do as far as paying off
loans versus
starting to invest and kind of where to
even start phenomenal cool how much is
in your checking account
uh we have about 40 grand
in checking and then four or five and uh
kind of an emerging a little emergency
uh separate account okay um and it's
just sitting there kind of doing nothing
and your wife is what
um she's a speech-language pathologist
she works part-time from home right now
for the covenant two phenomenal
careers with high income potential
what's your household income
uh
right now it varies um because i work in
the emergency room so hours kind of
swing but generally it'll be from
140 to 160 yeah yearly yeah i think both
of you get kicking in you probably break
the 200 pretty quick between the two of
you very good yeah very good okay well
what we know and what data data tells us
in 30 years of doing this is that the
quickest play between where you are now
and wealth is first to alleviate debt
because it's the biggest blocker for you
on wealth building
and it adds risk to your life and so
we're going to attack the student loans
with a vengeance
if i'm in your shoes
and to the point that your friends think
you've lost your mind
okay and we're gonna get on tight beans
and rice rice and beans budget we're
gonna take all the ot we can get and
we're gonna drop 39 of the 40 on this
student loan today and we're going to
put a tight written budget together and
begin to attack the rest of this you
will be blown away that you're going to
be debt-free in under two years maybe as
quick as a year
oh wow but you're gonna have no life
during that time you understand that
yeah yeah and we just you know you don't
have a life anyway you don't spend money
yeah we we take cheap vacations and kind
of you know make one dime thing but yeah
but what if you did nothing except pay
on debt for one year and you made 160.
oh by the way you said you said you had
150 but we just put 30 or 40 on it so
you got 110 now i mean how quick can you
pay off 110 if you didn't do anything
else you might do it in a year yeah we
could probably get rid of it real fast
yeah and see then you got the whole rest
of your life
to become wealthy without that stinking
sally mae in your spare bedroom
yeah
yeah that's what we teach think about
what do you think about you know because
the more we talk about it the more we
think of oh we don't have any
investments you'll get your investments
you're going to be making 200 and some
thousand dollars a year and no debt
you'll be able to invest like a maniac
all right well you know i told my wife
i'd call an f but i think everything
you're saying she said you would say oh
i think she set you up yeah
yeah hang on i'm going to give you a
gift i want the two of you to go through
ramsey plus our financial peace
university and i'm going to give you
ramsey plus a membership for a year
because you guys have got real potential
if you'll follow what we're teaching i'm
going to give it to you free won't cost
you a thing i just expect you to watch
the dadgum videos and go do what we
teach i want you to win dude hold on
it's our late wedding gift to you kelly
will pick up
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host thank you for jumping
in america this is your show open phones
at eight eight two five five two two
five ken coleman ramsey personality
number one best-selling author and host
of the new book from paycheck to purpose
the clear path to doing work you love
is my co-host today so we'll take your
questions about your life your career
your job which he talks about on ken
coleman
on the ken coleman show every day on 75
radio stations a podcast on youtube and
we'll take them right here as well and
we'll talk about your life and your
money free call at triple eight eight
two five five two two five christy is
with us in asheville north carolina hi
christy how are you
hey dave i'm good um thank you so much
for taking my call sure what's up
um uh first i wanted to say thank you
because um just going through your
program we are debt-free including our
home yay and thank you yes um so we are
and we're doing step four and we're
about to start step five
our daughter is seven years old and
we're trying to decide between the 529
or the esa and
kind of leaning towards the esa because
by the time she's 18 that'll probably be
enough because we don't want to put too
much and you know pay for stupidity
so um
so just kind of wanted your opinion on
the differences
okay all right well to clarify if your
home is paid for you're a baby step
seven
and so now you're saving you're
continuing to save for retirement
continuing to save for
uh
college but this is all just wealth
building baby step seven's just become
wealthy and outrageously generous so if
you have an emergency fund you're 100
debt free house and everything you're at
baby step seven but anyway
um the esa and the 520 and are kissing
cousins obviously they're very similar
esa's educational savings account
it is only
one thing
it is only
two thousand dollars a year
and it is only for people that make less
than two hundred thousand dollars of
your household income
and it only grows
tax free
and there is no tax deduction for what
you put into it and so if you put a
mutual fund into an esa it's going to
grow tax-free
for the number of years you can put up
to two thousand dollars per year into
that and that's it
very simple very cut and dried it can't
be anything else
529 has a bunch of things under that
heading
a lot of which we don't recommend
for instance prepaid college plans with
some of the states are technically 529
plans
there's another kind of 529 that locks
in the investments and they're frozen
you can't move them once you pick them
they're fixed the entire time no
flexibility bad 529
there's another kind of 529 that's a
life phase where they move the
investments to more conservative
investments less risky investments as
the child ages automatically i don't
want you to do that i want you to manage
the money
okay the only kind of 529 we have is
where you pick the mutual funds just
like you do in the essay so they're just
a like like that you invest in them and
you completely control them they will
not move unless you move them
and no one else is going to do it for
you and you're in charge okay just like
the esa now so once you've done that if
it's that kind of 529 the differences in
the 529 the esa are not many both are
after after-tax investments both grow
tax
free
both allow you to control and move the
investments inside of them as many times
as you need to and within the mutual
fund families particularly is a great
idea okay so all of that's the same
you're you do not have an income limit
of 200 household income limit of 200 000
on the 529 and you are not limited to
the 2 000 per year most 529s allow up to
10 dollars a year some even more
so if you want to put more money in or
you make a little more money
that type of 529 does exactly the same
thing but allows you to put in a little
bit more and deal with a little bit more
or if you're like if you're playing
catch-up and you make 300 000 a year you
want to dump some money in that's fine
but if you got a baby
and you make over under 200 grand and
you can drop two grand a year into it
you're gonna be just fine you're gonna
you have a lot of money you have 150 000
bucks probably in there but if it's in a
good mutual fund by the time that baby's
18 and like you said that's enough to
get start making some really good
choices you're probably going to have
some other wealth if you want to add to
it
and you're going to be in really really
good shape so very well done it's an
interesting discussion and it's great to
get ahead of it and it can it really is
because when you start to think about
you know if any investing advice or
thinking about in you know putting money
away and watching that compound
it doesn't have to be a lot and that's a
wonderful example on how you can well i
mean 150 000 for one kid is more than
enough for any kind of quality education
that you're looking at today i don't
know about 20 years from now well that's
a great point that's a whole other
discussion yeah but it's a good
discussion though it really is because
higher education
i think it has problems uh it's very
susceptible right now there's no
question i think this idea that they
just get to keep raising the price
forever is over i do think that is over
i think you're gonna see the cost of
which i think you'll see a splintering
um you know i think you're going to see
more and more organizations training
people
for the jobs at hand google's already
doing this they've come out and it's
very very clear move into the
marketplace and you're going to see
other large companies come alongside of
them so
that should be plenty of money we hope
uh i think it will be but that is a
separate prediction and conversation but
the cost of college and and higher ed is
going to have to
it's going to have to be reckoned with
because i think this this student loan
of course we got this great documentary
coming out borrowed future it's going to
absolutely punch all this right in the
face and i hope tip the domino i believe
borrowed future our documentary could be
dave the tipping point that finally i
believe
we make this a more mainstream
conversation yeah you know
we all are pretty much in agreement that
the student loan program is an epic
failure absolutely we're all pretty much
in agreement that this unfettered flow
of money out of washington
to these universities has caused them to
without without reservation raised price
after price price after price after
price so the supply of cash has driven
the price up unbelievably yeah and then
you add to that the pandemic comes along
and now they want to charge just as much
for you sitting at home that's right now
there's no football games yeah well now
there is but i mean now there's no
campus experience no now there's no this
or you've got all this woke stuff and
other stuff going on to the point people
don't they're not even going for
education anymore now we're going for
the cultural experience right and uh
nobody wants to pay 200 grand for that
anymore no and the swollen endowments
right we got all this money sitting over
here and we're not helping kids that
need some financial aid the narrative is
just really snowballing poorly yeah it's
not it's not going to go well for higher
ed um and i'm not against higher ed no
we're not no we are not we're we're
proponents of it but uh uh once you be
sure and check out borrowed future it's
going to be anywhere that you want to
plug in to see a paid documentary you'll
be able to watch it um it's coming out
the uh
in october uh the 13th 13th i believe it
is yeah i think so
hope that's a friday
no correction do we have that right yeah
what is it what are you saying
14
okay okay good close enough you'll be
able to find it right there in the
middle of october yes sir borrowed
future it's a big premiere we did a
whole thing here the other day with it
it's
the whole team watched it and it will
make you so angry when you see how nasty
these people are behind the scenes
this is the ramsay show
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just 30 a
month get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over 70 dollars a
month by switching to pure top just go
to puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
ken coleman's new book is from paycheck
to purpose the clear path to doing
work you love
[Music]
ken this is um
more than just climbing the career
ladder this is more than just making
more money yeah this is
about income and impact everybody wants
to make a difference in this world we
just do it doesn't matter where you're
from what you believe
uh your politics doesn't matter
everybody wants to make a difference and
there is this world view of work that
says i just work to be able to get a
paycheck to be able to live that's the
provision piece but you and i know that
there's contribution and that's what
that title in four words really outlines
the provision is the paycheck but
purpose is the contribution and this is
a seven stage clear path is what this
book is about that not only helps you
figure out what meaningful work is what
work that i love to do is what is this
work i was born to do this contribution
i was created to make it only helps you
there but then it walks you through the
journey it's not just get clear it's
then get qualified how do you get
qualified the right way for less money
but gets me into the door how do i get
connected so opportunities show up and
knock on my door how do i start where do
i start the right place so that i'm on
the right ladder how do i get promoted
that bigger shovel hello more money more
impact how do i get the dream job and
then what what does it mean to give
ourselves away that's just a real quick
you know pass through the seven stages
but it is a clear path that shows you
what you could do and tells you that you
should do it and uh it demystifies this
climb that so many people think and you
know i was just thinking for a moment
when i talk about this why did i write
this book and what is how does this play
into the money game that we talk about
i've never once now i'm sure there's
been one or two
but i've never once in my time here
seven years at ramsey solutions heard a
debt-free screen where the income did
not go up on some level
and there's more to it than just
you know well we were getting after it
and we were trying to hustle through it
there was a vision
and that's what drove everything else
the intensity the gazelle intensity is
about the vision the baby steps give and
this idea of working for purpose uh it's
more than just income and we can help
you get the bigger shovel and move up
but more importantly wants you to do
work that you love so that when you get
to the end of your life dave you look
back and you reminisce on the impact you
made you don't regret that you just
worked for a paycheck and that's what
this is about yeah this is a a lifelong
guide yeah this isn't a question you
need a better job no no this is not uh
this this is going to walk with you the
whole way
building your career helping you step
through the leadership ladder
making an impact coming home and going
because what satisfies you and rings
your purpose bell today won't ten years
from now that's correct your vision
grows i've always run ramsay for 30
years based on purpose but my purpose
has evolved and yes it is absolutely for
sure that's right and so that would be
true in any career path i'm no different
than anybody else in that regard yeah so
if you pre-order today the book will
come out november the 9th and we will
ship them to you where they're on your
doorstep that day
you're going to get also
the get a promoted bonus pack 20 bucks
for the book and it includes over a
hundred dollars worth of stuff
now here's what comes free the promoted
the get promoted audio lesson from ken
the disc assessment
and from the paycheck to the the from
paycheck to purpose live event
and a 30-day free trial to ramsey plus
and more
and over a hundred dollars worth of free
stuff total to get you started and get
you set apart from the competition
ramseysolutions.com to pre-order the
copy of the new book paycheck
from paycheck to purpose only twenty
dollars again street date on this is
november the ninth our question of the
day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings they
do a great job that's it they have free
samples free shipping the new promos
they run all the time you'll save even
more use the promo code ramsey to get
the best possible deal today's oh sorry
dave go ahead rules and restrictions
apply cut him off folks i'm so excited
to get to amy's question from kansas i
applied for a job with a salary range of
16 to 18 an hour which would be a raise
from what i'm making now i went to the
interview and i know i did well they
looked up how much i should get paid for
the job based on my credentials and it
came out to about 25 dollars an hour i'm
afraid that their budget may get in the
way of me being considered for the
opening this job is very specialized and
it's not something everyone can do what
would what i should be paid
disqualify me from getting the job so
what amy's asking here is is hey they
looked it up and they think i'm going to
want 25 an hour uh but uh this is what
they think you're not going to stay
because you're going to get 25 that's
right so what do i do so here's the deal
it shouldn't keep you from getting the
job amy if you communicate properly and
the fact that you've already they've
already told you well we think it's 25
hours what uh what you could make you
got to go hey
it was advertised at 16 18 or that's
what you told me and i'm thrilled to
jump in at 18 i'm ready to go or
whatever they offer i want to prove
myself i want to grow i want to do this
work don't let that bother you i think
this is a good fit you got to
communicate that and i think that
humility but just straight up honesty
that you want the gig and tell them why
you want the gig
don't let their worries and their fears
or what you think may be their worries
and fears fit into this you just tell
them i want the gig and i'll be thrilled
to take the gig so
here's the thing
the kids my kids years ago there's a
thousand years ago they were teenagers
it feels like but they had this thing
what they did and they called it awkward
turtle right
and that was if a conversation is
awkward yeah
what do you do oh this is awkward it's
an awkward moment right right and you
know that's what this is that's exactly
right and the best way
for the elephant in the room to
magically disappear is to say
there's an elephant in the room great
it's so true
yeah yeah he goes away yeah here's the
elephant
you guys looked it up
and this job pays 25 an hour you don't
have the budget for that you're afraid
i'm gonna leave because somebody's gonna
offer me 25 an hour i'm saying i'm not
doing that i'm taking the job you need
to hire me this is a done deal quit your
fretting yeah you say that poof yeah
there's nothing to be tense about here
yeah yeah just hold on the only question
whether they believe you on that or not
but
here's the thing people are paying some
ridiculous figures yeah for jobs for
people to move now i'm hearing just some
bizarre numbers on things oh out there
just to get human beings to show up to
work yeah it's going to blow their mind
when you tell them you want the gig yeah
they're going to look at you like you
got horns growing out of your head you
know we get in trouble sometimes that
boy i've been married 23 years coming up
on 24 years and the biggest trouble i've
ever gotten into dave with stacy is when
i try to assume or try to anticipate
what she's thinking as opposed to just
talking to her plainly or asking her
questions when i try to anticipate or
try to analyze something that's not
there boy we get this thing all worked
up on our head and it's not that big a
deal
just tell them i want the gig there's so
much low-hanging fruit here that i could
come with
there's no way that you could know
what's in stacy's head because it's way
smarter than yours this comes to mind
doesn't it it's just one item
you're absolutely right that's just one
of the myriad of reasons why i shouldn't
do it
[Laughter]
oh my gosh
no i mean yeah that the thing is
if
if something is weird stressful
um
the
the the demons around this they don't
like light yeah and when you shine light
on it they run for the corners the
roaches run for the corners as soon as
you turn the lights on and awkward
conversations have that sense to them
that
you know this is a difficult yeah thing
for me to cover yeah this is a hard
thing for us to talk about this is a
weird thing for us to talk about
uh but by talking about it it loses all
of its power it's so true yeah and many
times what we think is going to be
awkward for us isn't awkward for the
other party so just be an adult
have a good posture a good spirit about
you and as you said i was in your shoes
i might be thinking she's gonna leave
and take the twenty five dollars
i love that so why do i wanna put her in
there only to lose her in just a few
months i want you to know i've already
thought about that and i plan on staying
and i'd be honored to take this position
i would like to know how i can even add
more value over time to where i could
make 25 but you'd be happy to pay me
that because i made you 50 dollars
that's cool so i mean that kind of a
conversation is really powerful and oh
yeah as a follow-up after an interview
that would be pretty strong yeah they'll
be in a hurry to sign you
i think so yeah
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage evan and liz are with us
hey guys how are you hi dave great dave
welcome where do you all live
we are just north of detroit in michigan
oh wonderful okay like rochester or
ferndale
between rochester and detroit perfect
cool well good to have you guys welcome
to nashville and to do with that free
scream how much have you paid off
93 000 in 27 months hey
good numbers and your range of income
during that time uh we started around 80
and finished around 1 30. good what do
you guys do for a living uh liz works in
the home
and i work in uh systems administration
a lot of automation powershell that kind
of thing cool i.t computers i can tell
that that kind of stuff yeah so i got to
ask real quick what's what led to the
big jump here that's a big jump yeah uh
we got gazelle intense uh at some point
during our journey we we got to the
point where we couldn't scrape any more
off the budget and had to just get a
bigger shovel um so how'd you increase
your income 50 grand yes
yeah i know it sounds crazy um
uh certifications and a mixture of that
and getting the right job um just found
a you change jobs uh employers um so
just working my way up yeah so you got
qualified and you got promoted very good
there you go nice good work wow and he
got the olds company to pay for the
certification they paid for some
furthering education and then he
leveraged that wow
very very good
well those search are very valuable
obviously
well done good for you guys what kind of
debt was the 93 oh a little bit
everything but mostly student loans
student loans overwhelmingly student
loans how much of it was student loans
i'd say 85 oh wow hardly anything else
yeah yeah yes we had a tiny car loan
a tiny medical loan yeah how long you
all been married uh nine years yeah
yeah what happened uh 27 months ago two
years and some change
yeah we finally had the uh i've had it
moment that you've talked about
where we were making very decent money
and all of a sudden all of it was going
out the door to other people and it
didn't make a lot of sense to us to keep
that around so we listened to
your book on a road trip or i did for
work and
it just made sense it clicked it was
within like spitting distance oh we
could do this like it's not just far off
thing that like only superheroes can do
like we can just make this happen wow
that's a good line i love that yeah
there's some depth there's not just for
superheroes we can do this yes and you
are superheroes by the way but yeah just
the same so you came home from the road
trip and said liz i've been listening to
audiobooks uh no i said we should sign
up for a financial piece
and she said well we had heard about it
before um but our good friends at our
church um he was leading the class and i
was like fine i'll do it oh that made it
up
um and so then we took the class
together and
i felt like for the first time in our
marriage we were really aligned on
what our plan was going to be yeah
financial peace university your friend
is teaching it you join the class yeah
okay
i'm always interested in this i mean
i've been doing this for 30 years but
i'm still it's always intriguing to me
because i know how my brain works when
i'm going into something like that i
walk into that class i've got all of my
cynical shields up i mean
cynicism is a spiritual gift for me i
mean you know it's just like i i i was
i'm thinking there's this is greasy this
is slimy this guy's trying to get my
money
and uh and i i'm gonna be pretty cynical
you might not have been that jaded but
um but you still have to not know what
you know it never is what you think it's
gonna be you know what i'm saying yeah
you think it's one thing but it was
something else what were you thinking it
was gonna be
and what was it
i think for me um i thought it was going
to be kind of this like
health wealth prosperity like just
trying to make yourself rich for the
sake of making yourself rich and i think
what really sold me was your vision of
generosity to people
um that it just had
it's not just about you it's about it's
so that you can help others and um i
used to be a teacher in detroit before
we had kids and so i just felt like that
really resonated with me this is an
important way to
get our situation together so that we
can do more of what we want to do for
other people okay so yeah
yeah that does change that changes the
nobility of it um to say it's about
others and because it is yeah but it
changes the spirit on how you're going
um and so you just come home from the
first class and say game on we're doing
it huh
yeah um
i mean it was overwhelming at first um
when we ran our initial numbers i think
it was like
in five years at this trajectory um
then we'll be debt free and
um
yeah but we just
saw the lord's faithfulness i think
every month just like
paying off more than we even
anticipated we'd be able to pay off in
little ways
um
and so i think that motivated us and as
we saw our
on our spreadsheet yeah it just the time
kept decreasing and decreasing so yeah
evan it's fun when spreadsheets quit
working
it's going faster than we thought this
is going good yeah it builds up
emotional psychological spiritual
momentum yep absolutely yep 100 wow wow
i want to ask you this you just talked
about that overwhelming you know it's
just so much to take in right
and you go home and you put the first
plan together five years boy that feels
like forever right
but at some point you get to
that class and i'm just wondering how
much the community of other people going
through it
help you not be so overwhelmed with the
climb you're not alone speak to that and
what that felt like going through it
with other people yeah absolutely i
think the transformation in our marriage
was
we were at a point where we both felt
like we were dealing with finances
separate
um and then all of a sudden we started
having these conversations and i think
the same thing happened within our
community a church where we're not
having to deal with the separate
struggles yeah but now we're very open
with our numbers very i mean we just
televised our numbers
right everybody right
we can be open with that we say hey we
struggled hey we never talked about
finances the first eight years of our
marriage for seven years of our marriage
and we were it wasn't good like we
didn't have shared values we didn't have
these shared things and i feel like it
opens a avenue of vulnerability
that's powerful can i think a sense of
freedom that yeah you're not defined by
this like it's okay
this doesn't define who you are as a
person
yeah there's no stain on you there's a
brighter future removes the shame yeah
yeah that's good way to go guys
heroes man look at you how's it feel to
be free amazing so good just
yeah was it worth the sacrifice it was
it was worth it and worth it for our
kids and
um
just we have hope for them for the
future um so we're really what was the
weirdest thing you did to cut spending
down to nothing
i don't know about cutting spending we
lived really minimally um
but
he did some funky things for side gigs
before he got the job promotion oh okay
yeah i think the weirdest thing was
score keeping at a table talk hockey
tournament one weekend
for like a total hundred bucks
score keeper yeah craigslist man no not
just score keeper table table hockey yes
yeah that is this is like on your resume
right here man i love it that's fun
well done yeah score ding ding i love it
yeah
by the way don't call us and tell us
there's not a way to make extra money
the man made a hundred dollars score
keeping score keeping for table top
hockey yeah
this is awesome i love you guys yeah
this is that's you're my kind of folk i
like that well done hey we got a copy of
the legacy journey for you that's a copy
that's the next chapter in your story
moving on to baby step millionaires
you're on your way without a doubt and
uh congratulations we're very very proud
of you also a copy of total money
makeover for you to give away to
somebody get them started like that
audiobook got you hooked and then you
end up in financial peace university and
now you end up here 93 000
lighter
all right it's evan and liz detroit
michigan area 93 000 paid off in 27
months making 80 to 130 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
[Applause]
[Music]
their church and their group at
financial peace everybody cheering them
on that's amazing yes well done
good community you gotta have people
around you loving you well this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today proverbs 22 3 the
prudence see danger and take refuge but
the simple keep going and pay the
penalty
dale carnegie said be more concerned
with your character
than with your reputation your character
is what you really are while your
reputation is merely what others think
you are in a social media age ken that
is a good thing right there to read
again yes it is
be more concerned with your character
than with your reputation yeah your
character is what you really are
while your reputation is merely what
others think you are yeah there you go
just like that turns out dave too that
when you actually are a person of
character your reputation's really good
most the time
generally yeah yeah yeah but with social
media they oh you mean it all can take
out yeah sure sure people take shots
that aren't true but those that actually
knew about me about this place you know
but a stranger doesn't get to say what
they think dave's dave ramsey's
reputation is in my opinion stranger
doesn't know you i don't i discount that
you know they got to know you anybody
who knows you friends people who work
closely with you you have a reputation
this is what everybody hears and says
out there very different that's all i'm
going to say okay that makes sense you
know okay when you're a person of
character your reputation with the right
people takes care of itself yeah i got
you okay
tyler with the ones that matter yes
tyler's in state college pennsylvania hi
tyler how are you
hey dave doing great how about you
better than i deserve what's up
yeah so my question is related to
business and checking accounts i'm a
business owner i've always operated my
business out of a business checking
account along with a business debit card
as the business scaled up over the years
my expenses are becoming a little bit
higher and more frequent and my current
card only has a 2500 limit um and
each time that i go above that i get a
call into the bank and each time they're
really pressing me on the business
credit card
and just today when i went to do it they
actually denied it all together and
weren't going to let me do it unless i
upgraded to their business credit card
so i guess my question is um what do you
recommend that like how are you running
your business being like a multi-million
dollar business and all that what's your
recommendation there
uh it's time to change banks dude
yeah that's what i'm thinking yeah
see they got confused
about who the customer is
yeah the customer was sitting in front
of them telling them what he wanted and
they start putting demands on you on how
you're going to use your money
in order to have the privilege of doing
business with these doofuses i'm out of
there man the spirit on that is pitiful
yeah
i don't care even if it wasn't in
violation of what i teach just the way
they treated you today dude
right that's what i'm talking about so
here here's what we've had to do uh
we've got i think uh
lord i've lost count because i don't
keep up with it daily anymore i used to
be real concerned with it but anymore i
think we've got 150 people carrying
debit cards out of our thousands
um
and a whole bunch of others that have
access to the numbers in order to do
orders with you know around here for
business purposes so
um
you know we've got a bunch of them i
obviously have a business debit card on
this place and the revenues here north
of 300 million a year so
um
i i have low tolerance for trying to use
that card and not buying whatever the
flip i wanted to buy okay yeah i mean so
uh i've we've had discussions with the
business banking
unit
um here and said look uh my card
i'm not i mean you can put ten thousand
dollar twenty thousand dollar limit on
it the number of times i'm gonna buy a
car on a car is zero anyway so i don't
really have anything i don't i don't
don't buy
uh stuff like that all the time but i
also don't wanna not have access to
money when i've got millions of dollars
in your bank that will piss me off
because of your little debit card rules
but uh so we've had on my personal debit
card from the business had them give a
special dispensation
they should do that for you
um and you know 2500 is ridiculous it
ought to be at least five
and um
and you can look at it and you'll
probably be surprised the number of
times you go above five unless you're
doing a bunch of travel or something is
unusual anyway
yeah yeah so unusually low so um yeah
you need to change banks based on that
spirit
but uh you know we've got different
uh people inside this you know for
instance if one of our live event
producers is going to book a block of
rooms you know we're going into a hyatt
and we're going to take down 150 rooms
and they want a card well obviously
you know a daily limit is going to be a
problem on that so you know we and
that's how we use our debit cards here
so we we have some interaction with the
bank on a regular basis but we also have
uh higher than normal limits on some of
the daily amounts and total amounts on
the cards
obviously the cash has to be in the
account to coverage as a debit card
that's not what we're discussing here
but i think more than anything else what
you're discovering is you have a bank
that doesn't understand your value as a
customer and you need to find one that
does value you by the way we did change
banks and one of the reasons was the
old bank that i've been with for a
thousand years uh got bought up and
bought up a bunch of stuff and became
much more corporatized and became
inflexible
even with an account our size
they started giving us a hard time on
all kinds of different things and we're
just like you know what i'm not
negotiating with you people
you're just a foo flipping bank i mean
there's one on every corner there's a
lot of would like to have our account a
lot of them like to have your account
tyler i'd go get somebody else what are
you thinking i think i think you're
absolutely right you know it's your
money and uh these are somebody who made
a decision on the fifth or sixth or
fifteenth or twenty-fifth floor
and uh
i think the spirit is absolutely um it's
wrong they don't wanna help you grow uh
they just got their rules and i'd take
off i'd go talk to some other bank and
go hey here's the deal here's what i'm
looking for
and and look them in the eye
and uh interview them interview banks
just like you would
like one of our elps i'm getting ready
to hire you for my banking services yeah
i'm a small business are you good enough
yeah stay out of my way can you let me
do my thing if so i'll bring my money to
you what's happening is this that guy's
dealing with a branch manager who's got
pressure on him to meet the quota yep
that a certain
he has to move a certain number of
credit cards certain number of business
credit cards a month and he's got people
breathing down his neck he's got a quota
like he's selling encyclopedias
door-to-door exactly right and these
bankers have been reduced to use car
salesmen yeah these car salesmen are
much better people
and so uh sorry about that used car guys
you guys are excellent compared but i
mean they've been reduced to sales
people that have quotas yep i mean if
you work in victoria's secret and you
don't sell a lot of small underwear
that's not what they
gage you on
you can sell no small underwear and work
a victoria's secret as long as you sell
as long as you sell their credit card
because that's what they want oh they
want you charging small underwear okay i
didn't know where we were going with
this i was i was waiting to see what was
there's just nothing there there's there
it's just it's the same thing with most
of these companies yeah you go in a
department store why do you think
they're pushing the card on you they
make more money on that and they do the
stinking merchandise it's just sitting
on their shelf it's become that credit
card game and that's what these guys are
doing this stupid bank here yeah this
bank deserves a good firing hmm
i like it
you're fired yeah plenty of banks by the
way
i tell you what you know i would i would
go interview the smaller banks yeah bad
as bank of america i'll just bet you oh
i should have asked him yeah i'll bet
you it's bank of america it's that's the
way they act it's a big bank or bigger
yeah it's not it's not a small local
bank
small local bank would actually care
what you think yep and uh that's what
you need to go with by the way get you a
good regional bank or small loan that's
my thing too we moved to a we moved to a
local that's what we did and they can
handle us i mean
we we got a lot of money over there but
they can handle it so yeah that's not
like we're mr
like jed klamat and mr drysdale or
something but um y'all don't even know
who that is out there you poor people in
america certainly your television
deficit
you don't know about the beverly
hillbillies i i feel so happy right now
that you just said mr drysdale kelly's
feeling the same thing we're the same
age we're not going to say the age so
kelly doesn't hit me after the show's
over
i know i know you're a little bit older
but mr drysdale that is classic tv right
there that's classic i mean but i mean
that's a banker who was beholden to the
rich oil barrier
in the beverly hillbillies okay and he
ran around all the time trying to make
his customer happy that's what you want
it's been since the 1950s and 60s with
black and white tv since bankers
understood what their freaking job was
that's so good and it's not to sell you
a credit card that's supposed to make
you the depositor happy yeah oh man
what a lost world do we live in i know
i'm gonna go home and watch the beverly
hillbillies it's got to be on something
i've got two references to them in three
hours you have have you seen a show
lately no it's when you were channeling
i'm having flashbacks okay from my
childhood that's all it is it's an old
man thing the old man flashbacks ken
coleman good job today good job james
childs good job kelly daniels in the
booth i am dave ramsey we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
you